can I tell you a secret
I'm working with an Avenger
oh my gosh whoa we are right in front of
Grand Central Station in the beautiful
New York City day four on Hawkeye I mean
it is already
very quickly archery lessons training in
LA on the stunt side of things
hand-to-hand combat I love that this job
left me no excuse but to get to a place
where I could come here and be shown
something and I would be able to pick up
on it quickly the kind of hook for us
was bringing a female superhero that
it's not about being superhuman it's
about being super skilled and funny as
anything we knew we wanted to contrast
her with Clinton you know the classic
buddy cop sort of energy of these two
Divergent personalities kind of meetings
it's pretty cool for me people are
trying to kill us
actually it's pretty bad when you think
about it hey Seinfeld it was just
wonderful she's a very very talented
actress
I'm begrudgingly sort of have her as a
partner and then our friendship grows
through it with a lot of wonderful fun
things transpire
so Kate is helping you with an Avengers
level threat
he's my partner
it's kind of stretch she's really
adapted digging deep and Mining and just
adding so much Dimension what Haley's
done with this character I think fans
are just gonna eat her up for saving the
holidays I'm just so excited to be a
part of the MCU I've had an amazing time
and I just feel very lucky to be here
right now and I'm excited to see what
happens foreign
[Music]
[Applause]